America's ruling class is constantly
denouncing this country as racist
there's only one problem it's not true
most Americans aren't racist they're
really nice people so evidence of actual
racism is getting harder to find
instead they fall for racial hate hoaxes
they make them up they disseminate them
they amplify them lady's example comes
from the state of Georgia late last week
Georgia Democratic lawmaker Erika Thomas
said she was told to quote go back where
you came from at a supermarket checkout
before that white man to come with me he
caught me instead of a bitching lazy and
go back where I came from because he had
a couple items that he wanted to get in
front of me and he said I had twenty
items in a tonight of lie whoa make you
that angry of course the press love this
because it bolsters every preconception
they've ever had bolsters their bigotry
another racist Trump supporter on loose
actually it turns out the man that
Thomas was accusing Eric sparks is not
only Cuban he's a liberal he came
forward and called her story a total lie
watch this she said a few words I stated
while you're selfish little bi TCH I did
say that that's all I said after that
and I walked out of Publix her Ward
stating on Twitter in her video stating
I told her she needs to go back where
she came from or untrue I am white but I
am Cuban I was raised with the Cuban
grandmother who didn't speak any English
Facebook I will make it public proven
facts all my statements are anti-trump
anti-republican anti racism anti bigotry
this lady does not know me she's using
this to get on camera for a political
purposes
I hate Trump stop calling me a racist
that's his defense
sounds like he's telling the truth
though mr. sparks well is he continue to
try to defend himself Thomas kept
harassing him watch this
by the way Thomas later admitted that
she was lying she admitted that Sparks
never said the things that she initially
claimed he said but it doesn't matter
her lawyer now says brace yourself for
this that spark should face criminal
charges for saying mean things to Thomas
watch this Thomas and her attorney
believed the incident was racially
motivated and Watts Parks to face
charges
this individual violated Georgia law by
placing her in reasonable fear of
receiving a violent injury that is a
crime in this state Dave Rubin hosts the
Rubin report on YouTube enjoins us
tonight Dave clarify this if you would
it's still America right with the First
Amendment but you can be criminally
prosecuted for insulting a lawmaker in
this country Tucker for now on when I
come on your show can we put a little
title underneath that just says it's
completely bananas because every time I
come on I think I can't get crazier it
can't get more bananas more bonkers and
it does I mean this is this is this is
just patently absurd at every level
whatsoever I mean first off you may have
heard the story of the boy who cried
wolf I think we all grew up with that
story we now live in a time of the
politician who cried racism I mean they
are using the false cries the senator
Howley correctly pointed out in the
previous segment they're using the false
cries of racism to silence everyone I
live in Los Angeles have you ever been
to a Whole Foods where you walk into the
the Express line and you have one thing
over most likely someone is going to
scream at you and it has nothing to do
with their race or your race of the rest
of it but if you really want to see how
pernicious identity politics is because
that's really what this is about of
course it's that the gentleman there had
to go back and sort of imply that it
that he's not even white in a weird way
he was using identity politics because
he's really Cuban and that too
then that should then create a force
field around him this is a set of ideas
that is doomed to implode on top of
itself and we have to call it out and
and just to shout out senator Holly
again I think your question was right
which is what do you do when you know
this is happening to you and you must
punch back you know these false cries of
racism they only work if we give them
power and a story like this and the idea
that now she's getting the the legal
system involved they had a little
personal private spat over how many
items can go in a certain Lane that's it
there was nothing racial here he
obviously did not tell her to go back
where she came from
which would be pretty freakin incredible
in and of itself in that that just
happens to be what we're all talking
about this week because of Alan Omar and
Trump so you know we just need to keep
calling these things out because
eventually they will run out of steam
yeah and shame will be reintroduced to
the public conversation that would be
nice I would I would I would definitely
enjoy it Dave Rubin
thank you for the clarity thanks my
friend